thank you
telepathy
psychokinesis clairvoyance
precognition
parapsychology enthusiasts claim that
these are all human capabilities
is this true if it is then who has an
interest to use it or to stop us from
using it
crashed into one of the towers
[Music]
[Applause]
I've always had the will to test my
limits
training helps me be fit
studying understanding better it's
logical
[Music]
but I've also experienced things Beyond
logic
in theater the whole troop does a
warm-up before every performance of
rehearsal
we had to stand in a circle feel each
other and jump together and land on the
ground in the same instant
without preparing
just feeling
when this worked it was like magic
as if we all had psychic powers
there are people out there who claim
that they have these amazing abilities
claiming that they can actually heal
people the status quo does not want
people having these abilities our mind
is not only the five senses and reason
there is more
some people claim that human beings have
superpowers and they say there are
governments studying the subject and
conducting secret research in a bit to
understand it and possibly to control it
could this be true
in my research
I found that interest in psychic
phenomena started in the 19th century
and peaked in the Cold War era and in
the 70s
governments and universities started
funding experiments on Psychic phenomena
someone like Chris French head of the
anomalistic psychology Research Unit at
Goldsmith's University of London can
tell me about what they found
hi Chris how are you doing fine thanks
what is parapsychology
parapsychology
is the scientific study of phenomena
which can fall outside of conventional
science so in particular
parapsychologists tend to focus on uh
extra sensory perception ESP
and that comes in three different
varieties one is telepathy the alleged
ability to for direct mind to mind
contact uh secondly precognition knowing
about future events before they happen
and thirdly uh Clairvoyance picking up
information from remote locations
without using the known sensory channels
abilities which mainstream science as
yet does not recognize in history there
has been numerous swindles in the name
of parapsychology I mean it is a huge
business absolutely I mean this is one
of the reasons that I am interested in
these kinds of issues is from like a
consumer protection point of view
because obviously there are people out
there who claim that they have these
amazing abilities in my view even more
dangerously claiming that they can
actually heal people they have amazing
powers of healing now they're charging
for those services not always but often
they are charging for those Services can
you remember any of these swindles uh
back in the 1980s
um there was a chap called Peter Popoff
the Reverend Peter Popoff who was a
fundamentalist preacher who claimed that
he could cure members of his
congregation he made lots and lots and
lots of money out of this and it was
noticed by a very famous skeptic who
sadly died recently James Randy that who
went on to one of his shows and realized
that pop-off wore a hearing aid long
story short Randy got a friend of his
who was an Electronics expert to come in
they figured out what frequency was
being used and they recorded popov's
wife passing this information to him
which he was then using to fool his
audience
foreign
very nice how did you do that
a bent spoon and half another spoon
I put it like this
and add this one like that and then I go
like oh
trick
yes but I have actually seen videos of
people who can really do that I
silly I am telling you it is just a
trick and I'm showing you how to do it
why can't they both be right
there are people who have Supernatural
powers and others copy them using tricks
just like yourself where are those
people who have Supernatural powers
in all the ones we hear about there
isn't any scientific evidence of their
Supernatural power did you know that
they once did an experiment and asked
the participants to assess two
scientific reports they asked the group
to assess a report with the title
telepathy in Psychology and ask the
second group to assess a report with the
title a study in neuroscience
the participants assessed the report on
Neuroscience as more scientific more
believable and more trustworthy in
comparison to the report on telepathy
it's normal what's the problem
both reports were identical
and the only thing different was the
title
I'm just telling you that's all
parapsychology research is not secret
anymore
now the CIA has admitted that they
trained agents to seek impressions of
distant targets
they call it remote viewing
to find out about this hemising process
and whether it would be when an Iranian
student group in 1979 took over the U.S
embassy in Tehran and seized hostages
the CIA used psychic spies to peek
inside the building
a down Soviet bomber was located in a
Congo jungle
thanks to remote viewers
[Music]
has given us information
assisted in the investigation in 1961 of
the serial killer The Boston Strangler
[Music]
Jones helped catch the Yorkshire bipper
who murdered 13 people in England in the
late 1970s
remote viewers were also used in cases
of disappearances
such as that of Millie Dollar in 2002 in
Ireland and Madeleine McCann in 2007 in
Portugal
definitely this is more than just a
spoon trick
is it a trick or isn't it
or is it that the real trick is to not
believe it and call it a trick
there is an interesting theory about why
we do not believe in parapsychology or
use it
Dean Braden president of the
parapsychological association can give
me more information on this Theory
hi Dean how are you hello in which areas
do they use parapsychology today
there are many many groups and teachers
around the world who are using remote
viewing teaching it and using it many of
the applications are about financial
investments so it is remote viewing
things that will influence the stock
market or other kinds of Investments or
finding minerals or oil so for cold
cases especially like murder cases that
have not been solved
for missing persons
and usually for cases that get stalled
because there's not enough information
that's where some law enforcement
agencies will go to remote viewers could
you tell me how much is the psychic
industry worth in the states in terms of
entertainment the psychic industry
around the world is worth billions of
dollars an estimate was once made that
the total amount of money spent on
parapsychology since the beginning since
the 1800s to now is approximately the
same as what is spent in conventional
Academia around the world for their
psychology classes in one month in one
month so that raises your question why
is it not being studied well so one
reason is religious prohibitions lots of
religions say that this kind of thing is
declared to be demonic then there's
scientific pressure science today is
built on a set of assumptions and those
assumptions May make it very difficult
to understand why these effects should
be true you also have pressure from the
governments because one of the aspects
of telepathy of Clairvoyance all of
these psychic phenomena is that you
can't hide secrets
You Can't Hide secrets in your head and
you can't hide Secrets behind closed
doors because a really good psychic can
get those Secrets our institutions our
governments our entertainment systems
all want to maintain the status quo
the status quo does not want people
having these abilities
is it possible that governments prevent
us from knowing about superpowers and
from using them
an interesting hypothesis for sure
but our belief in it requires that we
accept the hypotheses that these
supernatural abilities really exist this
brings us back to the first question do
these capabilities really exist
all my life I have loved science and I
see that science holds the answers to
most human questions
but unfortunately not all of them
[Music]
for a very long time scientists have
been puzzled as to how migratory birds
can know the directions of North and
South even in the dark and even when
there are no signs there are many
hypotheses including that there is an
amount of iron in the nerve cells of
birds which is affected by the magnetic
field of the earth and works like a
compass
but whatever the assumptions are and no
matter whether or not we know the reason
for this it still means that birds know
and will continue to know the north from
the south
are we like birds
do we have senses and abilities that
science still does not understand
or is the problem that signs hasn't yet
Advanced enough
[Music]
it is easy for one to explain a
supernatural phenomena
as a delusion
because it violates what one is
accustomed to
in one of the theater exercises I held
my breath for as long as possible the
longest I could go was three minutes
but one day I heard about someone who
held his breath for 24 minutes
I actually couldn't believe it
because for me it was a supernatural
phenomenon
I researched the subject and found that
it is true
Croatian diver named buddhimir subat
broke the world record for the period of
time spent without breathing
here I knew that there was a difference
between Supernatural and supernormal
too bad was not Supernatural
Zubat went beyond the usual I know
and nature allows one if trained when to
hold one's breath for 24 minutes and
maybe more
this difference is what Edsel cardinia
uses to explain the phenomena of
parapsychology
hi Edsel how are you I am do you think
that this part of the human capacity has
not been scientifically researched
enough
absolutely because I think we as human
beings we start and we have all kinds of
capabilities but then culture and
education from all of these openness
start straightening up say this is
reality this is how you must think this
is who you are and then it gets smaller
and smaller and every culture does that
in different ways but every culture does
that PSY refers to the scientific study
of phenomena that suggests that
Consciousness or mind is not just Bound
by the senses and research let me put it
in other words that we may be able to
know things that we should not know that
perhaps all of a sudden you get an
intuition oh my grandma just died
even though I do not know why I would
have that hunch because she is in
perfect health and then the following
hour you find out that precisely
when you have that intuition that's
precisely when she died in an accident
and that it was unexpected you know the
traditional way would say to just
disregard those phenomenons say oh
that's just coincidence
but actually there is a lot of
scientific evidence
that suggests these are not just
coincidences this just shows that again
we have greater capabilities and our
mind is not only the five senses and
reason that there is more
could you give me a little synopsis of
these scientific evidence that's not a
coincidence when a phenomenon like that
occurs in everyday life it is impossible
to say that it was not a coincidence
but then what I and other people do as
researchers is that we bring people to
the lab and we arrange the context so
that you can rule out that it was a
coincidence and then we for example
might say to the people you're going to
go to sleep you're going to have dreams
and I would like you to dream about what
another person is watching in another
room and you do not know what that image
is about there is no way that you could
know it but we would like you just to
have the intention to let your dreams be
affected by that image that somebody
else is watching in another building and
then you end up later asking the person
who had the dreams okay we have four
different images which one do you think
was the one that the person was watching
and if people just guess correctly a
chance they should guess correctly 25 of
the time and what we know is that people
typically the end of guessing
considerably more around 34 of the time
which when you do this dozens or
hundreds of times means that it passes
the Criterion for scientific
significance meaning you can say this is
not just chance what I did in a recent
article was to look at all of the
evidence experimental evidence for
perhaps psychology that had been
published up to that time 2018
and all of the evidence has looked
through statistical analysis show the
support for this phenomena that they are
valid they do occur that it is not just
people having you know delusions or just
guessing correctly and no that it they
happen
they are real
there are many things that science still
does not know how to explain
they say knowledge in the world is
divided into three parts what we know
what we don't know and what is
impossible for us to know no matter how
hard we try
the task of science is to transform what
we don't know into what we do
but our task is to know the difference
between things we don't know and things
which are impossible to know
do supernatural abilities of humans
exist the explanation of which is not
known but will it be known one day
or is it something metaphysical that
science cannot decipher
or is it simply a thing that does not
exist at all except in our Illusions and
desires
these are questions for which I am still
looking for answers I'm on my journey
and I'm also looking for more questions
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you